Bobo was really you know he is a super
fan you'll notice that he's wearing a
bag over his head because he'll be
unveiling his new face without hair can
somebody just walk him into the door
walking in like you can't see there's
eye holes I can see but I can't see the
mic that's it you can see but you can
see the mind now I could say Bobo has
been calling into the show for how long
Bobo about 27 years I'm gonna now let
you unveil your new look I want to say
something before you take the bag off
yeah this is an end of an era day with
this hair system it's been on me since
the mid eighties Howard do you feel
liberated not having your system I
finally do now and you know are you glad
that we were pushing you to get rid of
your toupee what is that
are you glad I pushed you to get rid of
your tube gas yeah since we met him as
you know Bobo now has lesions on his
head he's afraid it was from the hair
glue from his wig now for the first time
on the show Bobo will remove the bag
over his head
[Music]
it's so dramatic bro I wanted to a build
up here it's coming out very slowly time
to come out of the bold closet you know
I wanted to go scream put it back put it
back but you like do so much better
you have a good shaped head except for
the Asians yeah you look great
oh you really look fine now put the bag
back yeah let me see your old toupee say
goodbye to it we're gonna keep it here
at the shell we've a doji it was never
doing you any good is the hair system
truly want to try it on do you mind hope
you don't get lesions pal
here's Shirley who's been bald for a
long time who's finally gonna get some
hair he's gonna use Bobo's hair system
and let's say every day you walk that
house thinking nobody noticed